Speaker 1: Let's talk just briefly a few more
minutes about Carrie Lake. Carrie Lake came up
with a story that no one in my audience seems to
believe. And I don't know that I believe either.
Carrie Lake recently came out and said, someone
came to my house the other day and they offered me
a ton of money and a cushy job if I leave politics
and just get out of politics. And she says it was
someone known to her. Now, of course, as soon
as I heard this story, I thought to myself,
She's a loser so far. Why would anyone pay her
to get out of politics when she just loses?
She went on the Charlie Kirk show yesterday
using this very, very intense camera filter,
very, very soft focus filter that she loves. And
she elaborated on the story. It won't surprise
you that she isn't naming the people or person
that allegedly did this. Let's take a listen and
see if any of it sounds believable. Here we go.
Speaker 2: You were offered money, almost a bribe
from powerful people to leave politics.
Speaker 1: Tell us about that. Yeah.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Well, you know, I was on your
show, I don't know, a couple of weeks ago,
and you asked me about a run for Senate. Rumors
swirling, and I told you, look, you know,
dozens of people at this point, but thousands of
people have reached out saying you've got to run
for Senate. If things don't work in the court,
you've got to run for Senate. And I said, look,
my priority is this the governor's office, the
race that we won and our case. But if things
don't go right, well, then I'm not going to get
out of politics because I'm not going to let
the same people who stole this election take our
movement away and silence us. So I would consider
that. I told you that on your show, and that made
some headlines and that worried a lot of people.
And on Tuesday of last week, as I was kind of
getting myself ready to go to see PAC, I had a
a visitor at my door and somebody I know invited
the person in and they started with an offer for
a a fancy job title and I salary a position on a
board if I would just agree to not run for Senate,
to not be on the ballot, to just stay out of
politics, kind of it for two years. To which
I laughed. I said, Are you kidding me? I think you
do know that I walked away from a prestigious job
in a big paycheck. I'm not motivated by that. And
conversation went on and as I finally moved this
person kind of out of my house and said, I've got
things to do. No, thank you. It moved into, well,
what? What do you want to make this happen? We
want you out there, some powerful people back East
who really want you out back east. They they know
that I will win in a primary and I'll frankly,
win in the general election as well.
Speaker 1: Now, a lot of the story I mean,
there's a lot here that doesn't make any
sense. First of all, why would someone
who lost be seen as such a threat that
they need to pay her to get out? Well,
you could make the argument the strongest
argument would be that Republicans. So she
says this is someone known to her. She doesn't say
whether it's a left winger or a right winger. You
could argue Republicans want her out because they
wrongly think she will hurt them. And of course,
she's like, no, I don't hurt. I mean, I won and
I won the governor's race even though they stole
it. And I would win the Senate race if I do that.
So Republicans are just wrong for wanting me out.
The other argument would be Republicans want me
out because they are RINOs. They they they don't
want my type of Republican because Republican
to run. They want someone who is, you know,
like a mitt Romney, Paul Ryan or whatever.
Democrats would want her out because they
see her as such a threat to them. You know, we
Democrats need to pay Carrie Lake to get her out
of the race because she would defeat whoever
is the eventual Democratic nominee. None of
it seems very plausible, I have to tell you.
Speaker 3: Very concerned. They want to put
out their typical candidates. And so the the
conversation turned to what would it be? What
would your. Price. B, What's your price with my
prices? I want our elections to be run smoothly
and I want to be in the governor's office.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, this is idiotic,
not only because it's really hard to believe, but
the truth is, you know that deep down Carrie Lake,
although she wants to pretend you can't buy her
out, if the money was right, of course she would
do it, right. I mean, it's like, listen, Kerry,
you lost. You can run for Senate. You can run
around and do the campaign and the entire thing.
You might lose again. Or here's some meaningful
amount of money for you. If the money was right.
She would, of course, accept it. So it's possible
the story's completely made up. It's possible
that it wasn't enough money or it's possible that
really what Kerry like wants is to be Trump's VP.
We know that on some level, that's something she
wants to do. But the story as she is telling it
has so many holes in it. It's like a Swiss cheese.
Speaker 3: Where I belong. And I said, There is no
price. There's no price that you could pay, which.
Speaker 1: Is, of course, a lie.
Speaker 3: To make me go away or
the people of Arizona go away. We're going to
continue to fight. So I wouldn't take 100. I
wouldn't take a million. I wouldn't take
10 million. I wouldn't take 100 million.
Speaker 1: She would take 10 million.
Speaker 3: That's how important this fight
is that we're in right now, Charlie, to. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So listen, I'm curious whether people
in my audience believe this story. Obviously,
she's you know, the weird thing about not saying
who it was is if you're truly disgusted with
someone making this offer, why wouldn't you
name them? In other words, why are you trying
to protect someone that you see as a deplorable
person, making you a disgusting offer that you
would never accept? Why wouldn't you expose that
they offered this to you? The second part of
it is these stories do have an air of the Trump
subroutines. You know, they came to me, they said,
Sir, and like the stories are very often made up
or at least extraordinarily distorted. Three, as
I as I'm saying, it doesn't seem plausible based
on the facts. And then the other part of it is
the emphasis on a run for Senate from Kerry Lake.
She seems to be continuing to say, I'm eventually
going to be the governor. Because they're going
to reinstate me or instate me. I guess it would
be. So then why would she be talking about the
Senate anyway as the focus from these other people
if she's really going to be reinstated? Like I
know you're saying, but David, she's not going
to be instated, Governor. I know that. But if
we're supposed to believe she believes it, then
why is she even talking about running for the
Senate? She'd be too busy being governor. It's
all insane. And my question to you is, do you
believe this story? Do you think this happened
or any version of this happened or is it being
invented and contrived completely from the ground
up by Kari Lake? Let me know in the comments email
and send a tweet however you want to get in touch.
Curious to see what folks in the audience think.